I make shine you can't film my face and
you can't know my name because screw you
because making your own liquor at home
is about as legal as making your own
mess at home they're kind of skittish
and they don't like to talk much if you
get caught making your own whiskey or
gin you could face up to five years in
prison
no wonder home distillers stay hidden
I'm not trying to get arrested I don't
want anybody to get arrested for
something that's not gonna cause any
problems in a community something that
somebody does in the privacy of their
own home it doesn't matter if you're in
the privacy of your own home says
moonshine expert and author Matthew
Rowley you can in America distill
nothing at home not one single drop but
beer is completely different
Humber's enjoy the freedom to make
whatever they want however they want
this allows for innovative micro
breweries like this one in Santa Rosa to
emerge opening up the distillers
equivalent of a micro brewery isn't
impossible but the law makes it very
hard there are some states that don't
allow small craft distilling we're lucky
to be in California where they do allow
it Yussef journey spent years running
the successful ballast point micro
brewery before opening San Diego's first
and only distillery even here the law
keeps the two worlds separate beer is
out in the open but the distilled
spirits are hidden away in this room
that's made to look like a
prohibition-era speakeasies we've got
kind of a 1920s decor in here the tin
ceiling some old antique furniture the
decor is appropriate because in some
important legal ways distillers are
still stuck in the 1920s
red tape and expensive permits make it
hard for regular guys to open up micro
distilleries and even if the regular
guys had the time and money to open up a
full-scale distillery the ban on home
distilling would make it hard for them
to have the know-how the current laws
that prohibit home distillation tend to
inhibit the craft distillery from
practicing their craft before they jump
into a business you wouldn't think of a
chef opening up a restaurant without
Artie making food at home despite the
prohibitions moonshine is gaining
popularity and reaching new audiences
home distiller org is a site where
distillers get together to share new
recipes and distilling techniques and it
hosts more than 6,000 registered members
there's a great spirit of adventure and
people make really interesting stuff
max Whatman is active in the home
distilling movement and wrote this book
about moonshine there are no rules on
what you can do you can cross brandies
and rums and you can make things out of
Basel and you can make you can make it
out of anything you can do anything you
want when you get down to it now we just
enjoy living life and shine these are
some of the most proud people you're
gonna meet they're really delighted at
what they've created and they send me
bottles their stuff just their buttons
are bursting they're so proud they just
show up in the mail a bottle with sports
water I don't know and please because
you haven't drank it you haven't
experienced it who are you to say it's
wrong but we always hear that moonshine
is dangerous that it makes you go blind
properly made moonshine is no more
danger than properly made cornbread done
well it's fantastic stuff done poorly it
might not be something you want to drink
but in general if it's not adulterated
it's not going to be bad for you it's
not the moonshine that's inherently
dangerous it's the black market once you
create a black market you create a
criminal class capitalizing on that
black market you got a crowd of people
who are more interested in making money
than they were in making whiskey that's
gonna degrade the process in a free and
open society we don't need a reason to
make things legal what we need are
reasons to make things illegal does the
government have a convincing reason to
keep raiding distillers I don't think it
really has anything to do with the
thought process of really what the
damage is gonna
be to the person it's more of a of a
how're we can attacks this correctly the
very first tax levied on the American
citizen was a tax on whiskey and so
we're really dealing with laws written
by Alexander Hamilton and George
Washington and we kind of with Abe so it
remains
this is an actual disparate the officers
spite the carefully planned attempt to
defraud the government of taxes the
result of outdated liquor regulations a
market dominated by a few big names like
Jack Daniels and Jim Beam I would like
to see as many micro distilleries as
there are brewpubs and microbreweries
around the country because then we're
gonna start to see a lot more really
interesting spirits one of the unmatched
moonshines I've ever had that was a
batch of moonshine that had been made
out of Tomatoes it smelled like brushing
up against a tomato plant in the middle
of summer it was wonderful it absolutely
just had aa ggest in a jar written all
over it I never found anything as good
as that I've been looking but unless the
laws changed most of us will never have
the chance to taste anything like
Walkmans tomato moonshine we should be
free to do this as long as we're not
harming anyone
why not distill in order for the home
distillers to get their hoppy legalized
they're gonna have to come out into the
open they're gonna have to talk about
what they do
they'd have to organize and what is the
spark that makes them realize this is
what they have to do I don't know why
when you enjoy something what you want
to talk about it openly when you know
that you could possibly be arrested for
it there's no harm there's no foul you
know screw the law
Suns gone